à qui profite la théorie du complot à
qui ça profite vous êtes déjà posé cette
question
on la pose jamais ou très rarement et
pourtant elle n'est pas illégitime à un
moment où on en parle de plus en plus de
ces théories du complot du complot tige
du conspirationnisme alors évidemment ce
n'est pas nouveau des théories du
complot on en connaît tous y en a sur
des événements historiques 11 septembre
dont on fêtait le triste 20e
anniversaire récemment mais la
révolution française aussi les deux
guerres mondiales tous les événements
marquants en général y en a sur des
technologies des théories du complot la
5g les vaccins arn messagers etc vous en
avez sur des phénomènes naturels
ou physiques comme par exemple les
traînées blanches que les avions laisse
dans le ciel après après leur passage et
des théories du complot là dessus qu'ils
aient des théories du complot qui
réinterprète radicalement ce que nous
croyons être la réalité par exemple sur
la forme de la terre qui est sous nos
pieds
des théories du complot qui peuvent
porter sur des entités big pharma on en
a beaucoup entendu parler ces derniers
18 mois la cia les banques sur des
groupes humains également les francs
maçons les juifs sur des groupes qui
n'existe pas également vous êtes tous
peut-être entendu parler des
extraterrestes reptilien
qui contrôlerait le monde en secret ou
les illuminati pas jusqu'à preuve du
contraire ça n'existe pas et donc cette
théorie du complot elles ont toutes un
point commun c'est que ce sont toujours
des discours d'accusation elle pointe un
doigt accusateur
en direction d'un petit groupe
d'individus accusés de quoi de compléter
ses airs de se livrer à un acte
foncièrement malveillants répréhensible
sinon légalement du moins moralement et
pour cette raison là le complotisme est
un sujet qui a une dimension politique
éminemment irréductiblement politique
quel rapport avec la violence et avec le
pouvoir
et c'est aussi la raison pour laquelle
le complotisme a toujours été utilisée
continue d'être utilisé par des
démagogues pour flatter le peuple pour
lui désigner des boucs émissaires à
stigmatiser a persécuté par des régimes
autoritaires aussi pour disqualifier
leurs opposants cinquième colonne et
c'est l'ennemi l'intérieur et aussi
surtout pour voiler masquer leur propre
échec
alors pourquoi on parle tout autant de
la théorie du complot du complotisme ces
dernières années
une thèse qui dit que finalement tout ça
est une bulle médiatique entretenue pour
d'obscures raisons par les journalistes
médias etc
moi je crois l'un vers je crois que l on
est là face un phénomène tangibles
et que le complotisme nous influence
plus qu'ils nous influencer auparavant
et quand je dirais quand j'ai dit
auparavant je dire avant internet tout
simplement parce que nous y sommes plus
exposés et parce qu'on peut pas penser
un phénomène comme le platine ou le
complotisme
en le dissociant de ces conditions
matérielles techniques de diffusion et
platine par exemple il ya 20 ans disant
extrêmement marginale extrêmement
minoritaire n'est très peu aujourd'hui
vous à des groupes de plates east non
seulement sur internet mais dans la vie
réelle qui se réunissent chaque année
presque chaque année au brésil aux états
unis
tout autour du globe
et
ça ne peut pas le penser si on comprend
pas que internet et pas seulement
internet mais cette configuration
technique médiatique très particulière
qui repose sur un triptyque qui est le
haut débit les réseaux sociaux et les
smartphones a tout changé dans nos
manières d'accéder à la connaissance à
l'information
parce que avec ces outils là eh bien
d'abord on peut trouver littéralement
toutes les versions alternatives sur à
peu près n'importe quel sujet vous
cherchez une théorie du complot ti sur
un événement vous la trouverez avec une
connexion et avec un moteur de recherche
comme google et puis surtout les réseaux
sociaux vous mettre en contact en
relation avec des gens qui croient aussi
comme vous ce genre de choses et donc
vous permet de faire communauté avec des
gens vous allez vous aussi influencé
vous allez alimenter les croyances et
qui vont vous alimentez en retour
et puis c'est très facile de relayer de
partager ces choses-là massivement parce
qu'avec nos smartphones on peut
littéralement partageaient des millions
d'individus
ces choses là et un regard vous avez ces
plateformes de réseaux sociaux de vidéos
en ligne dont les algorithmes sont
friands en faite de théorie du complot
pas parce qu'ils sont complotistes mais
parce qu'ils aiment les contenus
sensationnaliste et les contenus
complotistes sont particulièrement
sensationnaliste puisque ils vous
expliquent qu'on vous cache la vérité
sur tel ou tel évènement il prétend vous
révéler la vérité
donc évidemment cette configuration là
au final elle donne une chance
historique au complotisme
à ce stade on pourrait se dire et
finalement
est ce que c'est si grave
est ce que c'est si grave parce que tout
ça est ridicule ces petites histoires
rigolotes mais qui prend très au sérieux
mais de plus en plus de gens prennent ça
au sérieux et oui ça a des conséquences
graves si on a eu par le passé ça
continue à en avoir on sait le rôle par
exemple du complotisme dans la
radicalisation politique politico
religieuse
terroristes également on sait son rôle
dans l'enfermement sectaire et y compris
dans des phénomènes de désocialisation
où des gens se retrouvent h 24 sur leurs
écrans ordinateurs rompant tous les
liens avec leur famille et leurs amis on
parle de familles brisées de gens qui
arrivent plus à communiquer qui coupent
les ponts finalement parce que ils ne
peuvent plus vraiment communiqué
et puis le complotisme est aussi utilisé
comme un travail de sape de la
démocratie
l'un des pionniers de la réflexion sur
le sujet un historien américain qui
s'appelait richard hofstadter qui dès
les années 60 avait bien vu que en
substance il expliqué que lorsque matin
midi et soir vous êtes exposés à défaut
d'information qui suggère que vos
représentants démocratiquement élus sont
des pantins la solde de puissances
obscures que le vrai pouvoir se joue
ailleurs la vérité est ailleurs que le
pouvoir est invisible que tout se joue
dans les coulisses que les démocraties
en fait est un théâtre d'ombrés et bien
vous en arrivez logiquement presque
fatalement à remettre en cause la
validité du système qui permet cela
c'est à dire de la démocratie libérale
le système qui fait notre procès de
notre prospérité pardon depuis la fin de
la seconde guerre mondiale
et puis
ce complotisme il vient exacerber les
tensions les antagonismes qui
travaillent nos sociétés en les
polarisant au point de faire éclater une
partie de ce socle de réalité que nous
avons en partage ce que la philosophe
hannah arendt appelé le monde commun or
que devient le débat démocratique
lorsqu'il n'y a plus de monde commun il
ya bien il se condamne à être un
dialogue de sourds ont pas pu définir
ensemble bien commun si on partage même
plus la même réalité
et ça ça a des conséquences parce que
si on tranche plus de désaccords par les
moues par le débat par la parole mais il
ne reste que la violence et c'est ce qui
s'est passé en janvier 2021 aux états
unis lorsque des partisans de donald
trump chauffé à blanc persuadé qu'on
leur avait volé l'élection
eh bien se sont insurgés monter à
l'assaut du capitole c'est à dire le
l'un des endroits les plus sacrés de la
démocratie américaine
est ce qui avait commencé comme un
mensonge complotistes a fini dans le
sens ya eu des morts au capitole c'est
la première fois que ça se passe comme
ça une alternance démocratique se passe
de manière aussi tragique aux états unis
depuis le 17e siècle
donc le complotisme c'est un discours de
diversion qui en plus nous diffère en
fait notre prise de conscience
collective sur les vrais défis auxquels
nous sommes confrontés c'est vrai défi
vous les connaissez le réchauffement
climatique le terrorisme
la santé publique regardez le rôle du
complotisme par exemple dans la dans la
défiance est dans la propagande anti
vaccination
est en fait le grand paradoxe du
complotisme c'est que en nous en
canalisant notre indignation vers de
fausses manipulations des manipulations
inventé imaginaire
eh bien il nous manipulent en fait la
seule manipulation qu'elle est là
alors à qui profite la théorie du
complot
vous avez compris à des charlatans qui
monétise leur chaîne youtube
complotistes lève des fonds sur les
plateforme de crowdfunding pour faire
encore plus de contenu complotistes
elle profite cette théorie du complot
aux illuminés parfois aux ennemis de la
démocratie toujours et en tout cas des
gens qui ont un agenda un projet
politique
donc si j'avais un message à faire
passer ce soir ce serait que le
complotisme a un coût et ce coût n'est
pas neutre sans même parler du coût
financier du complotisme un certain or
estimé à plusieurs dizaines de milliards
d'euros par an pour nos sociétés non non
il a un coût parce que
votre attention le temps que vous passez
connecter votre temps de cerveau
disponible en fait il n'est pas illimité
il est fini et donc il est précieux et
le temps que vous accordez au feq news
aux théories du complot c'est
concrètement du temps qui est pris sur
la connaissance validées
scientifiquement sur l'information à
haute valeur ajoutée
que des bataillons de chercheurs de
scientifiques de savants de journalistes
s'épuise à produire parfois au péril de
leur vie ils y laissent parfois
effectivement leur vie
donc je peux que vous encourager à faire
en sorte de faire barrage en fait à la
théorie du complot à vous engager ce
qu'elle ne passe pas par vous par
exemple en vous abstenant de partager un
contenu douteux issu d'une source fiable
médias peu fiables juste avec un geste
comme celui largesses d'abstention si
vous faites pas pour la démocratie si
vous faites a pour la concorde civile si
vous faites pas pour la santé publique
faites le au moins pour être amour
propre
parce que la théorie du complot c'est un
piège intellectuelle c'est un leurre
c'est un mirage la mirage dangereux je
remercie
[Applaudissements]